et
quels sont ceux parmi vous qui sont nés
avant 1987 et bien
connaissez-vous la micro composition et
je suis heureux de partager avec vous
mon expérience ce jour mon histoire a
commencé lorsque j'étais tout petit tout
simplement parce que quelqu'un me dit à
l'âge de 10-11 ans si tu veux gagner ton
paradis arrange toi pour que quelqu'un
te disent merci
chaque jour obtient m merci chaque jour
alors figurez vous que lorsque je
reviens de l'école je laisse mon sac et
je cours pour aller sur la route du
marché parce qu'en ce moment là vers 16h
17h le moment reviennent du marché et je
vais aider une maman apprend ses
affaires à rentrer chez elle à la maison
pour obtenir mon merci de la journée et
j'ai grandi avec et tout les jours je
vais tout faire pour obtenir un merci
figurez vous que dans les années 80 de
83 je reviens de france et je tombe sur
un discours du chef de la nation du père
de la nation qui dit tout ce qu'il ne
s'intéresserait pas à l'informatique
seront considérés comme tels à la fab
est au 21ème siècle
cela m'a interpellé
et j'ai ressenti un inconfort parce que
l'informatique
il n'est pas parti lui même matière
et je devrais je faire j'étais
responsable de la cellule de thau
formation et il fallait absolument que
je puisse faire quelque chose et je me
suis donc mis à étudier à utiliser cet
outil le z10 4e 21 mon premier
ordinateur avec un tas d'unités
centrales
le jour j'ai obtenu l'élément
complètement taire jeter tout je fais la
fête à la maison
les indices avec sept cas aujourd'hui le
maquette nouveaux smartphones sont d'au
moins un million de ko et moi j'ai
commencé à apprendre l'informatique avec
cet ordinateur
comprenez que je n'ai pas fait pour la
programmation est très vite je pensais
que je pourrais aller au delà
mais à l'institut on m'a confié la
partie d'un groupe pluridisciplinaire
on m'a confié de monter un dossier sur
l'équipement d'un futur lycée l'elysée
les collègues avec qui j'étais n'était
pas intéressé par l'informatique
parce que sa demande d'une nouvelle
formation qui n'avait pas envie de
suivre mais je continue le projet
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour on me convoque au
ministère on m'invite plutôt au
ministère avec les experts et les chefs
de projets
au projet a été rejeté parce que tout
simplement je n'étais pas informaticien
et donc tout ce que je pouvais proposer
comme type - n'était pas forcément ce
qu'il fallait et ce projet a été rejeté
maggie mon intervention
mes arguments ce projet a été rejeté
ça a été une gifle pour moi et là je
suis sorti pertubé il me fallait relever
ce défi mais en privé parce que mon
administration ne voulait pas du projet
que je préparais et donc au bout d'une
exposition je vais rencontrer une dame
je vais renconter donc une dame madame
ligue logo et à l'époque directrice de
nouvelles démissions africaine qui avait
un souci lui fallait sortir rapidement
un livre 13 emplois temporaires dans un
délai très court mais il se trouvait que
malheureusement son fournisseur habituel
ne pouvait répondre à ce matin que dans
un délai de six mois elle m'invite
après notre rencontre à ce bureau
elle convoque son star et je vais donc
rencontré cette dame discute avec elles
et à la fin de la discussion
elle va me proposer un manuscrit
volumineux il s'agissait du manuscrit de
milliers makeba je sors de là avec une
feuille de style et des éléments qui
sont commandés et gérante chez moi
qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire j'ai
réquisitionné l'équipe
le document qu'elle pensait avoir au
bout d'un mois j'ai pu réaliser ce
document suivant sa maquette en moins
d'une semaine
si gliese par la qualité du résultat et
du délai elle me demande comment je fais
j'ai bien ce pic et à ôter de la
maquette de ma commande et je vais lui
proposer ma maquette à moi parce que
j'ai étudié le dossier
j'ai c'est qui celui-là makeba par
rapport aux gens de cette personne par
rapport à sa stature et à l'autorité
je ne peux pas une maquette j'échange
les faire du style et finalement c'est
dans ma tête à moi qui va être retenu
voici comment laventure de j avais et
j'ai crié en privé va commencer à
révolutionner l'édition en côte d'ivoire
parce que avant 1987
la composition du livre pour la maison
d'édition conventionnelles ne suffisait
pas en côte d'ivoire avant 1987
tous ces éléments là étaient faits soit
en asie soit en europe soit au maghreb
et à petit du résultat que j'ai eu avec
la composition de son livre c'est à dire
la saisie la mise en page 6 po graphique
je vais faire rapatrier pour nos
éditeurs la composition du livre sur le
territoire ivoirien
bien d'autres vont suivre
je vais donc me trouve les verts les
imprimeurs travailler avec les
imprimeurs d'été le chanteur il puisse
faire ce qu'on appelle le coup j'ai
collé en termes de brochage pour
corruption également rapatrié la
composition et les imprimeurs avec qui
nous avons travaillé ont réussi cela et
du coup tout ce qui était considéré
comme littérature générale et les livres
parascolaires pour l'eau l'éditeur
nature ne se faisait désormais en côte
d'ivoire nous allons continuer à partir
de ce moment-là à développer auprès des
entreprises auprès de l'institution
auprès des agences de communication
la possibilité de composer toute la
publication et c'est ce que nous avons
fait depuis donc 1994 j'allais dire ça
va être pour nous le grand succès
lorsque nous l'avons reçu du ministre de
la culture le pays le plus de
l'innovation dans le monde de l'édition
et l'imprimerie en côte d'ivoire
[Musique]
depuis 1994 nous sommes donc écouté
depuis 1994 nous sommes donc invités à
faire en sorte que cette spécialisation
puisse être connue parce que la
formation non plus ne se faisait pas en
côte d'ivoire et donc pour la sous
région nous avons commencé à recevoir
pays voisins des responsables d'un pli
mairie des responsables de maisons
d'édition à qui nous avons partagé notre
science à qui nous avons partagé le fait
que désormais la composition du livre la
mise en page du livre puisse se faire
avec l'outil informatique
aujourd'hui c'est avec beaucoup de
fierté et de respect mais je vois les
publications diverses qui se font aussi
bien chez nous aussi bien dans les pays
voisins
par rapport à ce que nous avons pu
apporter volonté et détermination
voici le message comme pourront faire
partager que nous voulons diffuser
auprès de notre jeunesse d'ici et
d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui la nouvelle technologie nous
offrent d'autres opportunités
d'autres possibilités d'autres
spécialités croyez en vous et avancées
liées à repasser demain et à vous ne
laissez pas vos envies dans les mines 2
août
ne laissez pas vos désirs dans les mains
des autres apprenez avec passion
aiguisez vos talents fort je vous des
convictions fortes et action action
action
ne laissez pas vos talents est
emprisonné par la peur d'entreprendre
ne laissez pas votre vie est refusé par
envie d autres ne soufflait pas vos
compétences par le fait de tourner en
rond et ne pas trouver votre chemin
derrière chaque volonté il ya un chemin
des liens chaque volonté il y à des
hommes et des femmes que vous êtes qui
pouvait faire un saut de changer notre
monde est avant gardiste vous le pouvez
vous le dvi alors dit oui
maintenant je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]